ça va être difficile comme défenseur
n'abandonne jamais je vais partir du
principe que c'est pas un fils victor
mohammedi une belle citation un hymne à
la persévérance dont découlent à sa
croupe de leçon vous avez à peu près
toutes les leçons sur ce ne soit les
aliens pas là quand j'étais à 6 et à peu
près beaucoup de sous merci
pagé 1 j'ai effectivement là l'idée ce
que voulait dire c'est que la patience
est une vertu que très souvent part du
principe quand on évoque des vertus
elles émanent de qualité à tous
la personnalité intrinsèque à l'individu
et à qui on vous connaît cette vertueuse
un postulat que non seulement je refuse
mais j'aurais eu des vertus se
construisent donc la persévérance aussi
c'est le premier message que je voulais
faire passer c'est que votre capacité à
atteindre vos objectifs de défendre et
de vous ensuite tu restes le reste
évidemment de même chose à la
conjoncture le contexte les autres
envers gérard manset va vous aurez
remarqué que je dise tu perds mes
objectifs je ne veux pas parler de
rigueur parce que quand on parle de
rigueur par définition il ya qu à lèvres
c'est le disent quand vous voyez la
grille et les deux hommes ne s'étaient
pas vus et ceux qui construisent la
veille si ceux qui ne font rien pour la
construire
ça c'est le message de 12 à 20 ans je
préfère encore peut-être objectif a vu
ici je vais y arriver parce qu'il a
laissé 2
on a tous des objectifs dans la vie
parfois dans les même pas conscient mais
on les a soumises et que les vertus se
construisent retrouver cette attraction
de ce cas
donc par définition ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire quelque chose pour les
construire ce quelque chose c'est un
truc que vous connaissez tous assez de
travail la persévérance est une vertu
qui se construit par le travail on vous
dit adhérer si il n'y a pas de réussite
passe par définition n'est pas facile
parce qu'il faut poser
moi je considère que la valeur travail
est mère de toutes les vertus
je me suis permis cette image de la
cigale et la fourmi et le vague de la
chandelle qui est révélatrice finalement
de ce deuxième message que je voulais
faire et que j'ai aussi traduit par la
visitation que laquelle je fais assez
assez souvent référence qu'est celle de
benjamin franklin dit que faire et se
défaire sont deux choses bien
différentes
on a tous des objectifs pour la course
on dit de venir quelqu'un avant beaucoup
d'argent de réussir professionnellement
personnellement mission définition on
est mal barré donc il faut bosser alors
un petit exemple pour cent coureurs
tout le monde le connaît ce et supervise
l'homme le plus heureux du monde
parce qu'il est né en jamaïque parce
qu'il est super musclé en réalité pas
vraiment regarde c'est rapide m
selon l'antique parce que le son est
coupé sur le mode travail se fait dans
les coulisses et la compétition c'est la
partie facile
l'htc paul ii
kraft a conscience dit paris n'est pas
sain de courir
alors n'attendez manquerait bien mais
grosso modo ce qu'ils disaient c'est la
compétition c'est la partie la plus
facile de son job
la partie la plus dure c'est celle que
personne ne sait quand il concourt
découvre les trouve f de la fongs du
poids il s'entraîne ibos ravi fédérer
égale la médaille d'or les records du
monde et tous les millions d'euros
qu'ils voient
alors tout à l'heure je vous disais je
préfère le terme de l'objectif pourquoi
ce que je préfère le cadre d'objectifs
parce que jusqu'à présent tout ce que je
vous ai dit c'est quand même assez
évident on a des objectifs pour les
atteindre
faux procès mais si on est là
aujourd'hui qu'on se pose encore la
question c'est qu'il ya un problème
ce problème de ma vie c'est l'idée d'en
retirer un déficit de penser à ça donc
de pensées négatives de mauvaise
conception de mauvaises acception
notamment celle de la réussite
la réussite pour bosser ça vous arrive
et sans génie marocain en la maintenant
on leur dit c'est quoi réussir et vont
me dire gagner de l'argent en 2 achetés
de waldshut malheureusement ce n'est pas
que ça la réussite si c'était que ça ce
serait facile et pas ce qu'on peut
considérer que cette femme là on pourra
aussi vous la reconnaissez
évidemment vous la reconnaissez c'est
donc à la russie se reconnaissait elle a
donné toute sa vie cette femme pas
gagner d'argent pour aider les autres
alors est ce que la pauvreté a été
erratique et non parce qu'elle a échoué
non elle n'a pas échoué quand donc ça va
marcher parce qu'on l'avait cité ne
passe pas par la voix et passe par une
longue lettre et de la voile ça c'est
fondamental
on nous enseigne beaucoup trop dans nos
écoles de commerce comme la vôtre celle
dans laquelle j'ai été qu' il ya cette
fameuse pyramide de maslow on avait
besoin il faut respirer vous c'est
incroyable ce qu'on nous apprend pour
respirer
il faut manger s'habiller faut dormir on
a besoin de payer pour aller à l'école
que nos avions et tout ça vous savez
pourquoi pour alan drame encore de
l'argent moi je n'aime pas cette vermine
de masse mosquée l'un vers sa relation
non c'est pas le principe de la vie
principes de la vie
c'est vraiment cette confusion de
lettres de l'avoir dit certaine manière
quand on a une mauvaise conception de ma
réussite et ben du coup on a une
mauvaise conception de l'échec
je vous ai mis cet électrocardiogramme
que j'avais déjà rentré dans une
précédente présentation y avait déjà ce
chinois c'est les battements du coeur et
les battements du coeur ils sont à mon
sens à l'image de l'oeuvre la vie celle
des phases ascendant 2d phase
descendante pourrait considérer qu il
pas à s'entendre c'est la réussite et
les phase descendante c'est léger sauf
que vous voyez
sa part ça revient sa part ça devient
fou parce qu'on reviendra par exemple
bien c'est que l'enjeu de la vie il est
justement dans ce creux des creux vous
allez en connaître les creux j'en ai
connu si vous en a cité un certain de
tout à l'heure il faut s'y préparer
soit vous considérez que c'est à l'échec
c'est une donnée vous êtes foutus la vie
s'arrête c'est la ligne droite
l'échec c'est bien l'abandon et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous dit les vainqueurs
n'abandonne jamais on vous dit pas les
20 carats vous disent toujours vous dit
il n'abandonne jamais et l'abandon c'est
l'échec dans ma petite de type
biologique m'a fait ma personne c'est
sympa d'ailleurs merci vous a dit
cofondateur du collectif du 31 mai le
collectif 31 mai nova n'avoir pas existé
si on avait ordonné il n'avait pas
abouti
si on avait abandonné et tout prêter à
ce que l'on attend d'eux diplômés
étrangers donc dans un pays qui n'est
pas le nôtre
l'ennemi réguler mais si je puis me
permettre
louise de l'intérieur de la france on
était mal partis pour gagner mais on a
gagné parce qu'on n'a pas abandonné et
tout à l'heure vous verrez clé une
deuxième condition qu'on ne pas
abandonner et on y viendra donc devenait
si vous voulez réussir ses jupes c'est
le le message que je voulais faire
passer alors il ya une autre homme à
l'autre il est un autre notre problème
est le mal que je considère comme étant
l'un des moments les plus importants de
notre société c'est le déterminisme
désigné par ici
benedetti alors moi je suis ch'ti
s'appelle style la mission ne serait pas
chez c'est de réussir
évidemment personne ne sait que je paye
encore d'un diplôme toujours pas c'est
que à vendre intégrer hec gt1 et les
moyens du bûcher travailler mais à force
de le révéler que le message ne passe
pas utile peut importe maintenant c'est
petit et je suis fier de l'esthétique
donc je vais vous citer un certain
nombre d'exemples si ça veut bien marché
on ne s'est pas laissée petit dans les
seins à l'air libre
personne ne sait que c'est un ami vient
d'une famille modeste
çà et là mais vous savez quoi sert un
fils de postic est devenu patron de la
poste
je plaisante pas c'est pas une blague 10
de postiers est devenu patron de la
poste aujourd'hui les patrons de ces dlc
faverges et y fait des bêtises
c'est une fille familles modestes salles
et aujourd'hui il ya des stars comme
beyoncé qui portent des habits elle a
bien réussi
tout à l'heure je le disais on ne
réussit pas sans les autres mais aussi
grâce à lui
la creuse et à tanger en 99 de mémoire
et c'est comme ça qu'elle peut décoller
pourquoi parce qu'elle a saisi
l'opportunité que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure nous est l'opportunité c'est un
élément qu'on ne maîtrise pas définition
la chance comme la ma chance on ne les
met 10 mhz alors soit on dit j'ai pas de
chance on s'assoit on s'arrête
ils sont en forme
on se dit que tout est possible et on
continue de croire et on essaie
d'avancer au regard plein d'autres
effectivement lui il est bien connu mais
c'est milo de ciani fils de berger
devenu l'enjeu aujourd'hui n'est juste
pas trong d'ynna holding est un maniaque
immobilier il est aussi dans la
pétrochimie dans le plastique et ce2 et
lille semblait que c'était la première
fortune il a montré un peu plus de deux
milliards et demi de dollars de richesse
personnelle fils de vergy images
il fallait agir on ne connaissait pas
lui c'est 78 % des parts de marché de la
charcuterie au maroc aujourd'hui avec
des marins vendre français et les
bouchers piste boucher lui même couché
puis c'est le fondateur de taille
pareille il a commencé course et nous
sommes le 6 armand cesari a commencé
dans l'ébénisterie dans un petit atelier
aujourd'hui les patrons talbot talbot
ses 70 millions de dirhams de chiffre
d'affaires annuel laissez moi un pays
qui a quitté l'école
il voulait faire les beaux-arts ça n'est
pas de vous faire et vous arrivez à
avoir le bac il avait pas le pacte il
s'éteint
et ville et dépasse les 250 d'euros par
an
il a économisé économise il économiser
music hall acheter un petit lopin de
terre à 10 min
aujourd'hui certaines de ses oeuvres son
siège l'euro-2006 de grandes
personnalités et tout le monde veut
lécher les séries comme j'ai la chance
de le connaître quand j'étais tout petit
biberon le sait pas mais il a fait les
premières des rollings cause des eaux
il avait fait un tube dans les années 60
68 par les cheveux me semble-t-il dit
qu'on ne savait ce qu'il faisait son
père était marchand de véhicules
voilà vous les citer parce que je vous
ai donné quelques patrons beaucoup
d'argent elle c'est pas l'argent qui
fait paraître la vie et les dents 41
dans l'ancienne médina de casablanca
autant dire qu'elle est pas parti du bon
pied la galére elles sont diplômées
d'affirmer aujourd'hui il reconnu
internationalement pour son engagement
et à la sauver et d accompagner nombre
non négligeable de mère célibataire elle
est devenue alors elle c'est la patronne
de rm mamounia une grande assurance
elle pourrait presque je la cite parce
que ces familles moyennes modestes de
cette polytechnicienne c'est aussi
monstrueuse monstre de cette preuve
vivante que quand il bosse on obtient
forcément ce qu'on cherchait à obtenir
elle était aussi mis en avant le sens
qu'on était interbancaire on l'a
débauché pour aller présider l assurance
du président aujourd'hui
benhamou son multi ou coller ces
nouveaux corps dans un autre registre
beaux gosses des fils du régisseur de la
folle exactement il est passé aussi à
laisser leur fille suri s'appelle affole
le son et lumière aujourd'hui il lance
un nombre incroyable de jeunes artistes
marocains et c'est un acteur
incontournable de la scène musicale avec
vichy les cofondateurs
impossible d'y associer des rares
c'était un artiste monnier qui a réussi
à faire balancer droits de tous les deux
mairies grâce à ses droits d'auteur
il faut savoir qu'à l'habitude et chez
l'adulte et chez elle parce que ses
parents lui avaient dit non du
changement skype a chuté à 15 de ses
fils est allé parti a chanté à l'olympia
lui plongé exactement et l'école est
tout simple le patron du maroc il a
commencé informatique de 1500 dirhams un
patron d'une belle société qui est
présente en libye un peu partout dans le
monde arabe en afrique
ils sont tous bloqués alors je vais pas
vous mentir et à la mick loupé mais y en
a comme m ce sont des exemples sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer
il s'appelle pas ce petit ils ont pas
fait l'addition
ils sont pas que les classes prépa pour
tous ils n'ont pas tous fait un jeu
c'est donc c'est possible si c'est
possible pour ces possibles pour vous
alors en somme fois je vous ai dit tout
ça et je donne ma petite recette ni un
qui moi j'aime bien les choses
chaque fois que je dresse and critics
les noisettes bienvenus je suis lâche
michel de la pensée
c'est lâche michel de la pensée et si
c'est le mobile y croire tout à l'heure
je vous parlais que du collectif du 31
si on n'avait pas cru en nous on
n'aurait pas fait il faut que vous
puissez croire d'abord peu importe les
raisons tangibles qui existent pour
épicer croire en vous croyez en vous
parce que si vous croyez en vous vous
allez vous aimez moi personnellement je
m'aime je m'adore je m'adore c'est très
bien pensé et c'est un bon message
il est des prétentions qui sont bonnes
être prétentieux ça ne signifie
forcément se sentir supérieur aux autres
la prétention je blague je me l'appliqué
à moi mais je suis arrogant vis-à-vis de
moi-même
ça me permet de repousser payer ça me
permet de me donner les moyens de
posséder parce que bosser c'est pas
facile c'est pas naturel complètement ce
que pourrait penser
donc moi je vous invite vraiment à le
faire et pour tout vous dire c'est pas
une blague qui m'est arrivé quand
j'étais en classe prépa j'avais ça à
parcourir mètres devant le miroir dire
tu vas tout défoncer des super héros et
super man et sauf en été mais bon j'ai
raté les mots je les ai passées
je les ai réussi lorsque l'opportunité
mais des données de ramasser des
concours saisissez toutes les
opportunités qui vous sont donnés c'est
ce que la paix la prévention constructif
alors attention vous vous restez humbles
avec les la prétention des livres ou
même juste vous mais parce que c'est le
seul moyen de devenir tout ce que je
vous ai cité de devenir celui que vous
voulez devenir lors d'un présent
précédente et xv amusé elysées à la
question qui vous inspire j'avais
répondu celui que je veux devenir pas
mais l'outil avis pas nager sa peau au
marché et là vous aurez guéri ce n'est
qu'à ce moment de régler
je vais finir doute pressé la chanson le
conte est dans un stade ça se passe pas
bien c'est à de vous ou un autre trop
rapidement comme elle a terminé au même
point automne au taux attendu outre
edmond point automoto
merci